[Music]
Leonard Barkan: I've written a book about a
different Michelangelo.
It's still the same guy.
Michelangelo Buonarotti: Florentine architect,
painter, sculptor, poet.
But, it's not the
Michelangelo who produced things like the
"David," the "Moses," the Sistine ceiling.
It's the Michelangelo who produced things
for his eyes only.
So, the book, which is
called, "Michelangelo: A Life on Paper," is
about that life. It's really about his interior
life. And it's an archive of the things that
he put together when his mind was wandering
and his hand was wandering, and words popped
into his head or drawings seeped out of his pen.
For me, it's the incongruity, it's the
randomness, it's the accidental quality, it's
the private quality of these sheets of paper
that makes them fascinating. At the same time,
it's an archive of his practical life, because
it turns out that he did all kinds of different
things on the same sheets of paper which are
a mixture of bits of poetry, memos to self,
lists for foods and expenditures and moneys...
all mixed in with drawings that range from
everything from doodles to sublime figure
sketches. But the other thing we have, is
that we have private, passionate remarks.
The kinds of phrases that can only bubble
up from an intense and tortured soul.
He has at some point drawn a cherub
and he has also
turned the sheet ninety degrees and written
the direct quotation from a very nostalgic
poem by Petrarch about his own home territory
about the Vaucluse. But, as though it's seamlessly
connected, Michelangelo continues this Latin
poem by writing, in Italian, "Don't make me
draw tonight because Perino isn't here."
On this sheet he writes, "Lavoglia invoglia e
poi lascia la doglia" (Desire engenders desire
and then leaves pain). And next to it, he
writes, "Death is the end of a dark prison."
But in the midst of this, he has contracts,
he has angry statements and he also draws
a large, rather ungainly hand,
and two very long, extended bodies.
It is the strange interconnections
among some of these drawings and these passionate
utterances that point somewhere to a private
space, that I think, without these pieces
of paper we would never glimpse.
And, so he loved words and,
of course, we know he loved
pictures. So, one of the ways that this book
tells its story about Michelangelo is to understand
that the connections between words and pictures
in his life were much more intimate and also
more mysterious than we might have thought.
We have these sheets with completely incongruous
and unrelated fragments on them. And for me
these sheets of paper, with their quite bizarre
and mysterious mixtures of words and images,
are very very much like dreams. Really, the
kind of dream that Freud analyzed in which
there are strange, unexpected juxtapositions.
Juxtapositions that if you look carefully,
and think carefully about the whole life of
the subject (whether that's a subject on an
analytic couch or a subject who is reclining
as he paints the Sistine ceiling), if you look
carefully at these mysterious, seemingly disconnected
utterances, you have a sense of what Freud
would call Michelangelo's unconscious.
[Music]